hi this is pressure Walker a group of
people decide to play Secret Santa to
begin each person writes their name on a
piece of paper and places that paper
into a hat each person then takes a name
from the Hat at random and that's the
person to give a gift to the draw is
successful if everyone gets a different
name so your puzzle is what's the
probability of having a successful draw
that is what's the chance that no one
gets his or her own name in the draw
Illustrated each person is getting a
different name but you could imagine
there's a different type of draw where
say person D gets his own name
this is not permissible because you
don't want to be giving a gift to
yourself so this is an unsuccessful draw
so your problem is to figure out what's
the probability of a successful draw and
you need to solve this for a group of n
people give this puzzle a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution so first we'll count the
total number of draws that are possible
the first person can draw any of the end
names from the group the second person
can draw any of the remaining names so
since one name has already been taken
there n minus 1 names that are remaining
the third person can draw from any of
the n minus two remaining names that
have not been taken by the first or
second person the very last person will
be stuck with just the one name that's
remaining to count the total number of
draws that are possible we multiply the
number of possibilities that each person
can draw this will be the familiar
formula of n factorial which is the
product from 1 to n now we need to count
the number of draws that are successful
so if you try and count this up like the
first person can select any of the N
minus 1 names but his own name the
second person can select any of the
remaining names hopefully not his own
name and hopefully that first person
hasn't already
selected his name the very last person
is one name remaining and hopefully that
name is not his own so if you try and
count this up it's going to be kind of
complicated so it's going to be
difficult to count so the trick in this
puzzle is you want to count the number
of drawers which are unsuccessful that
is you have at least one person picking
his own name so what we're going to do
is we're going to count the number of
ways at least K people choose their own
names in order to do that we're going to
need the binomial coefficient and choose
K which is a number of ways that you can
choose K items from a group of n how
many ways will at least one person get
their own name well if one person gets
their own name there are n minus 1
arrangements of the remaining people so
that becomes n minus 1 factorial
they're also n choose 1 ways of picking
that one person similarly you can count
the number of ways at least 2 people get
their own name there n choose 2 ways to
pick those 2 people and the remaining n
minus 2 people can be arranged in n
minus 2 factorial ways so this pattern
continues and in general we can say that
at least K people get their own name
we're going to multiply the number of
ways of choosing those K people which is
n choose K times the number of ways to
arrange the remaining possibilities
which is n minus K factorial so when you
simplify this formula you get n
factorial divided by K factorial and
we're going to keep that formula so we
have at least eight at least K people
getting their own name is equal to n
factorial over K factorial so now we
want to know how many of the draws are
unsuccessful so we've been counting at
least K people getting the row name what
we really want is exactly K people
getting their own name so we want to add
up at least exactly one person exactly
two person and so on so how are we going
to do this we're going to avoid double
counting by using the inclusion and
exclusion principle we add up the
numbers where they're odd the No
sets which have an odd number of people
and we subtract out the sets which have
an even number of people so this is the
formula we add up the ones where at
least one people are getting their own
name we subtract out at least two people
then we add back in having at least
three people and so on we subtract out
the number of sets which have at least
an even number and we add in the numbers
which have an odd number so you may
remember this from like a Venn diagram
if you want the probability of A or B
you take the probability of a plus the
probability B and you subtract out the
probability of a and B so when we
substitute our formula in into this
inclusion exclusion principle we end up
with the alternating series of n
factorial divided by the reciprocal of
factorials we can factor out n factorial
and we have the alternating sum of the
reciprocals of factorials so these are
the total number of ways the total
number of draws that are unsuccessful we
can find the probability of an
unsuccessful draw by dividing by the
total number of ways which is n
factorial so that will remove the n
factorial term and so we have the
alternating sum of factorials is equal
to the probability that we have an
unsuccessful draw now to get a
successful draw we take one minus the
number the probability of an
unsuccessful draw so that removes the
first term and we have the alternating
sum of the reciprocals of factorials
starting at 1 over 2 factorial and this
is an interesting sum this is going to
be equal to approximately 37% because
this is the power series for e to the
power of negative 1 or 1 over E so there
are many interesting things about this
one is that we have the constant e which
seems to come out of nowhere the second
thing is we have a 37% chance and that's
going to be fixed pretty much no matter
what size and you have it's
approximately going to be 37%
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you liked the video please
check out my books there links in the
video description